everyone is mine to torment you do well
to remember that your little monster
monsters are dangerous and just now
Kings are dying like flies
hey youtubers it's Charlie I hope you
guys all had a great Thanksgiving since
it is Black Friday and everyone is
stabbing each other with pens and
climbing over bodies to get cheap stuff
I thought it totally appropriate that we
talk about Joffrey Baratheon today so
I'll be doing my top 5 things to look
forward to for his character in season 4
but I'll also be addressing some of the
rumors that the actor Jack Gleeson is
going to be quitting acting after he's
done on Game of Thrones as well as the
new trailer that's going to be coming
pretty soon I've also got a special
announcement about a new show I'm
working on it's not quite ready yet but
I'll let you know what's going on if
you're seeing me for the first time or
you've never seen any my Game of Thrones
Season 4 videos then careful for
spoilers from the first three seasons as
well as book 4 so if you don't want any
spoilers then just turn the volume down
and turn automatic captions on because
automatic captions are awful but they
make for hilarious videos so the big
thing to consider about Joffrey in
season 4 is that his character has
really like one big moment obviously
we're talking about the purple wedding
but because he's a main character on the
show they give him a lot of extra scenes
and really expand his part in a really
interesting way so what we really need
to talk about is what's going to be
different about his character in season
4 number 5 extra scenes so if you saw in
season 3 Joffrey got a lot of extra
scenes a good example of this is Joffrey
Margaery and Geoffrey's crossbow it was
kind of a pseudo sexual three-way scene
even though none of them consummated
that relationship but there's going to
be a lot more of that in season 4
because obviously Joffrey's big moment
isn't just going to happen in that first
episode one of the really awesome
consequences of these extra scenes is
that it gives actors a chance to
improvise just a little bit not all the
actors on Game of Thrones improvise but
every once in a while there's a subtle
turn of phrase or a gesture that lends
itself to something like this I imagine
it must be so exciting to squeeze your
finger here and watch something die over
there number four more malevolence
so Joffrey will continue to get more
evil so obviously like a lot of the mad
Targaryen Kings Joffrey is a little bit
crazy and he's just gonna continue to
get crazier on the show he's actually
still pretty young he's still a teenager
so he's not going to go crazy on
like the level of Mad King Aerys and
tried to firebomb the entire city but he
will still be torturing Sansa and Tyrion
and anybody else that crosses his path
much to the chagrin of Cersei Tywin and
now Jaime now that he's back in King's
Landing to one of the really cool things
that's already changed in the show is
now that Jaime is back in King's Landing
early he has more chances to interact
with Joffrey before the purple wedding I
think secretly what we're all hoping for
is a scene where Tywin just jumps across
the table and strangles Joffrey in his
chair number three the rains of
castamere so if you saw my previous Game
of Thrones video that you know rains of
castamere is a Lannister theme and
obviously Joffrey is a Baratheon on the
show but in reality he's a Lannister so
I'm really interested to see during the
purple wedding if you hear it subtly in
the background they're not gonna do it
like in the red wedding where characters
played the song on the show during the
wedding like you would play like a
wedding march but because David Benioff
and DB Weiss kind of laced the theme in
really softly in the background whenever
our Lannisters on-screen I'm really
interested to find out if they laced it
into the background during the purple
wedding
number two the purple wedding I'm
talking mostly about the ceremony not
the feast that comes after even if you
haven't read the books you may have
heard the term purple wedding what it is
is it's a name given by fans to the
wedding between Joffrey and Margaery
Tyrell the reason it's called the purple
wedding is because Sansa where's this
hairnet with amethyst Senate which are
purple and she plays this really big
role in the wedding and the feast
afterwards the reason why the ceremony
is number two is because the scope and
the size of the scene that they shot so
David Benioff and DB Weiss said that
this is one of the biggest scenes
they've ever filmed they had 23 named
characters that is principal actors with
character names as well as over 200
extras on set that day it's the biggest
scene they filmed basically since the
premiere and my number one moment the
purple wedding feast so this happens
after the ceremony and is basically
going to be the most talked-about moment
on television next year I don't want to
spoil it too much but it basically
brings together a lot of running plot
threads and basically throw some
characters to the wolves so to speak one
really funny thing from an HBO
standpoint that I'm hoping for is that
they will promote next season using
save-the-date invitations for Joffrey
and Margaery the purple wedding will be
the wedding that you want to attend next
year but without spoiling
too much right below in the comments
what are your biggest questions for
Joffrey in season four and what are you
looking forward to most so to address
rumors that the actor of Jack Gleeson is
quitting acting after he's done a game
of Thrones in order to understand this
you have to watch an interview he did
recently a class cal college a student
asked him what his plans for the future
were and he just said that he wasn't
quite as interested in continuing to act
like acting as a profession just did not
interest him as much as a lot of other
things David Benioff and DB Weiss
actually guessed that he might go into
higher education he is one of those
actors in real life that's highly
learnin so I wouldn't be surprised if he
ended up teaching at a university
wouldn't that totally be awesome to get
a degree in history from King Joffrey he
also does these really cool puppet shows
with his friends when he's not filming
Game of Thrones those aren't online yet
but hopefully someone will post them
eventually in other related Game of
Thrones Season 4 news there should be a
season 4 teaser coming soon last year
around this time we got our first
voiceover trailer it's not a full
trailer it's really just an actor's
voice over a date so it won't be really
substantive but I'll be sure to do a
video as soon as they post that like I
said earlier too I'm working on a new
weekly show I'm not quite ready to
announce what it is yet but it's
basically going to be like a vlog where
I answer a lot of viewer questions and
do a lot of things that don't fit into
specific videos typically most of the
videos I do are just about a single show
like this is just about Game of Thrones
but I'm gonna be working on a weekly
show that allows me to combine a lot of
different shows together I don't know
what it's gonna be called yet but you
can leave your suggestions in the
comments below
here's my schedule for the rest of the
weekend so tonight I'll be doing my
Legend of Korra book 3 video I'll
probably post that around 8 or 9 o'clock
at night and then on Saturday I'll be
doing Sherlock series 3 they just
announced the premiere date in the UK
and I'll also be posting my part 2 video
for my Doctor Who 50th anniversary
Easter eggs then on Sunday is the
mid-season finale for Walking Dead right
now click here to get all my other Game
of Thrones season 4 videos and click
here to get my Doctor Who 50th
anniversary Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you